das selber betreiben sollte was klappt
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
und heute habe ich wieder kollege
kompanie christian aber erst bin ich war
selber er wird eher wachsen mit dem ball
jahre doch ich werde das video nicht zu
bekommen auf jeden fall bei uns leute
was ganz besonderes weil ich jetzt
einfach mal leise wer uns heute was
super special besonderes überlegt was
sicherlich den einen oder anderen
konflikt auslösen wird und was natürlich
auch bestimmt unterhalter wird und wie
hält und helfers nochmals challenge
einfach und zwar schnell heißt das ich
hab noch nie also dass das prinzip ist
eigentlich ganz einfach wir haben hier
so ein schönes schild auf dem schild ob
ihr könnt das gericht bis nein du nicht
nur einzelne ist einmal ein haken und
einmal ein kreuz so ich habe jetzt fünf
fragen über milch rausgesucht und
christian abt 5 franken bei sich
rausgesucht und wenn jetzt zum beispiel
christian mir ne frage gestellt von
wegen zum beispiel ich habe noch nie es
keine frage sein austrian ist in eine
steckdose reingeschoben jetzt nun mal
ganz ganz tolles beispiel als bei
sportarten ausnahme penis und eine
steckdose genau genau gutes beispiel
dann muss ich halt sagen so der
christian hat das schon mal gemacht oder
der christian hat das noch nicht gemacht
und dann darf er auflösen es eigentlich
ganz einfach da sind wirklich sehr
intime fragen dabei deswegen würde ich
empfehlen
bleib dran du selber ist es gleich
anfangen oder einem schlagstock kommen
bis 1 schnick schnack schnuck war ok hat
der anfang ich habe noch nie einen
anderen autofahrer den stinkefinger
gezeigt
das heißt ich habe das schon mal gemacht
ja aber jetzt nicht gesehen
willst du dich gar nicht trauen ja ich
hab so als habe zudem auch wieder kers
gesagt der erst mal eine frage von mir
ich habe noch nie mit anderen personen
zusammen ein porno geguckt das ist
einfach so die fans bis zwölf oder 13
jahren findet eine alter das ist echt
schlimm kamera noch eine heftigere story
okay wir machen heftiger nicht fragen
jetzt will ich auch etwas spektakuläres
von ihr solchen spektakeln gesagt haben
ja komm ich habe noch nie die schwester
eine sehr guten kumpels kristic wir dass
eine krasse keine ahnung woher soll ich
das wissen herr ich finde das gar nicht
so schlimm eigentlich so kenne herrn ein
hast du nicht falschen film
es muss jetzt sagen sie zu diesen soll
das geht eigentlich keine mehr ist er
verstehe ich ja sag mal hat ja die eine
oder andere jugendsünde riot ok ich hab
noch nie mein alter verleugnet nur um
jemand näher kennenzulernen ich möchte
aus erfahrung das hast du schon mal
gemacht weil ich vor alles im club
er trifft nur mädchen der praxis wie alt
bist du
bis 19 und erst hat noch nicht mal muss
dann tief sagen ja ich bin 19 20 wieso
ich bin 1920 so irgendwie kann ich hab
ich echt nicht warum ich das ding also
nie älter ausgegeben als du bist in
wirklichkeit ist
ich habe schon mal als erster aus kenia
ich war letztens im p1 in münchen
hey ich bin christin ich habe noch nie
jemanden einfach so auf den hintern
gehauen
also nicht richtig krasse fragen und was
soll ich dich einfach gefahren
ich habe letztens mal eine freundin
gefragt was hätte sie wohl gemacht wenn
ich bevor wir zusammen oder bevor wir
uns ja nicht mal mit der zusammenhang
erstellte freunde der freundin ich habe
sie so gefragt ja was würdest du machen
hätte ich dir einfach auf den arsch so
wir uns nicht mal gut kannten
wenn ich nichts ja okay weil wir es so
weit ist ganz klar eine schlimme sachen
ja wenn es so aus spaß ist und das jetzt
richtig knifflig ist okay egal nicht
dass es die nächste frage bin ich dann
okay passt auf die nächste schalten wie
ich wieder ich habe noch nie so viel
getrunken dass werner party rausgeworfen
wurde dass das nimmt seine frage ich
glaub mal du bist raus geworfen
wegen dir ja du hast noch nie so viel
geträumt was ich normalerweise bin ich
nie so ne aber ich war quellen und das
war's egal das ist schon länger her wo
ich war in köln
daraus könnte ich so eine story erzählen
aber nein wir lassen das also fakt ist
er wird schon mal raus geschmissen weil
er aber so ich bin ja auch keine ahnung
ich habe noch nie jemanden nach der
nummer gefragt
das hast du glaub ich noch nie gemacht
natürlich hat jeder schon mal gemacht
das war sehr intime frage alter wir
haben sonst hätte man die ich hatte bis
jetzt die krasseren fahren seit er dich
okay was auch nicht vollkommen von mir
ich habe noch nie in der sauna andere
leute beobachtet was heißt denn
beobachtet so wenn ich mal niemand in
der sonne was hast denn beobachtet die
sauna aus prinzip schäfer aus prinzip
kiefer was für ein skifahrer gefährte
voll auf die adresse nicht irgend ein
alter opa drin sind so leicht ihr sonst
was ich tue was ich wirklich was männer
seien ja nur alleine china so naja ich
bin ich von dem interesse
christiane junge hör doch mal auf alles
hier um zu schmeiß alles sieht voraus
mit diesem papier ding hätte mir egal
das war's mit dem video
wenn es euch gefallen die vielleicht
davon noch im zweiten teil haben wollt
ihr könnt ihr auch mal weitere ich hab
noch nie fragen in die kommentare aber
ein bisschen mehr ich glaube ich weiß
nicht wer das war schon intim alter also
so weit dass ich soweit gehen hätte ich
nicht gedacht und ich bin auf dieses
video auch durch moritz gekommen ist ein
kollege von mir also ihr könnt auch mal
moritz video abchecken lw beschreibung
christian könnt ihr gerne bei instagram
volk oder ich mache jetzt will ich
versuchen ein bisschen mehr zu posten
sollen so eine art blog nur ohne
schreien interessant da muss man doch
mal vorbei schnuppern
jürgens weiter mit meinem letzten check
dass ab diesem sonntag wie gesagt wenn
es mal was sagen dann tun sie das bitte
jetzt nicht